you know obviously this record with
dolph i'm assuming that that came from a
genuine place as well yeah we went to
the studio and did that like we we
didn't do no email [ __ ] like we actually
did that yeah kind of explain um you
know obviously rest in peace to dolph
i'm assuming this is a record that
you've had for a long time yeah um how
long ago was it recorded
um
like two years ago wow yeah we recorded
like
20 20.
you know what i'm saying we used to just
chop it up you know i'm saying here call
me out facetime and we'll facetime each
other every other week or some [ __ ] like
yeah i mean he was the best man yeah
how like was it like a little bit
difficult getting the record cleared
without him being here i mean because we
do know his people
are very solid and they you know man
yeah i had to go through some channels i
had to go through have to go do some
channels you know what i'm saying
managers record label
you know what i'm saying legal teams you
know what i'm saying they all they all
know who i am you feel me yeah i did it
myself i made them phone calls myself
you know what i'm saying i didn't send
nobody to do that you know what i'm
saying